logan is a masterful piece of cinema and
a beautiful send-off for Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine still some interesting scenes
and ideas ended up cut from the final
movie including a reunion with
Sabretooth mutant cameos and a tragic
flashback yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
it's Jan here and in this video I'm
going to talk about some of the scenes
and concepts rejected or cut from the
final Logan movie just before I get into
those I've got a cool giveaway for a
second set of Logan merchandise for a
chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe and leave a comment about
Logan or the deleted scenes on this
video the prize includes a t-shirt shot
glass is a dog tag bottle opener and a
metal notebook and for bonus ways to
enter check out the gleam link in the
video description below of course there
are spoilers in this video so if you
haven't seen Logan yet check out my
spoiler free review and come back here
when you've had a chance to watch the
movie an idea that was rejected early in
script development with a flashback
scene that would have shown exactly what
happens during the Westchester incident
in the final movie we get numerous
allusions to the catastrophe such as a
news report safety with an incident
similar to the one we see at the casino
in Oklahoma City occurred around a year
previously and that seven meters were
killed and over 600 people were injured
the original idea was that the flashback
would explain what happened with
Professor X and Wolverine in Westchester
and it was actually going to be the very
first scene in the movie
however the filmmakers thought it would
be more powerful if the audience was
left wondering screenwriter Michael
Greene's that he's interested to see
what fans theorize about the events but
knowing exactly what happened doesn't
matter as it's the emotional effect that
the incidents had on Charles Logan
that's important flashbacks were also
considered for other moments in Logan's
past for examples of some beautiful
unused concept art of alkali lake by
designer shake shack and there was
another idea for a flashback scene
featuring the location where the movie
villains lived a residence which
included a pool a helipad and a killer
view the unused concept art also reveals
an alternate design for the tank where
Charles was being kept by Logan and
curiously in some early sketches
it looks like Logan originally had a
little canine companion which might have
given him more of a Mad Max vibe and it
was an Oklahoma City where we might have
seen a reunion between Logan and Victor
Creed aka Sabretooth as the Logan movie
was being developed
Liev Schreiber expressed interest in
reprising the role of Sabretooth one
final time and an early idea was mooted
that Logan would seek out his
half-brother and former nemesis
Sabretooth for help it was never to be
though and the IDF fell by the wayside
but would you have liked to seen the
pair back together before Hugh Jackman's
retirement as Wolverine I gotta say I
love the tone they went for in the final
movie and various mutant cameos might
not have fit so well with that purr down
story still although the Wolverine clone
x24 was played by Hugh Jackman himself
if you get a smite sabre to survive when
x24 first appeared during that brutal
fight scene at the Munson family home
the dinner conversation that Logan and
Charles have with the Munson's could
have been much darker as an alternate
versions of scene with films where the
Munson's asked Logan if he's married
Charles replies that Logan was married
but that he killed her man Gould
explained that he didn't use that
version of the scene because it felt
just too dark at the moment in the film
that was meant to provide a little
levity especially with the events which
happened later at the Munson farm by the
way if that scene had made it into the
final film it's unclear what exactly
that would have meant to the x-men
timeline which after Days of Future past
appeared to invalidate the timeline of
the first three x-men movies at the end
of which Wolverine killed Jean Grey
early in the story director James
Mangold also toyed with the idea of
Logan reaching a group of other mutants
on an underground railroad during his
journey the mutants would probably have
been cameos by characters at Suns would
recognize however Mangold decided at
including them would have felt forced
given the movie's tone and ultimately
they would have undermined a loneliness
of Logan's world one character that fans
have been desperate to see alongside
Wolverine and for a long time was
rumored to appear in Logan it's Deadpool
it would have been great to see
Wolverine and Deadpool on-screen
together you know in a good film not
just x-men origins Wolverine but as Ryan
Reynolds explained the Merc with a mouth
wouldn't have mixed with the tone of
Logan Wade Wilson and Deadpool did get a
little teaser for Deadpool to complete
with a cameo by Stan Lee in the short no
good deed but the way that the movie
Logan worked out in terms of mood and
storyline for me it was better that
Deadpool wasn't part of the main film
the supervillain mr. sinister aka
Nathaniel Essex was teased in the x-men
apocalypse
post-credits with brian fingers taking
the third Wolverine movie would
introduce the villain properly however
later james mangold decided not to
include the flashy supervillain in Logan
and he wanted to keep the film very
grounded and step away from the huge
spectacle of the other movies and the
x-men franchise man goals wanted the
audience to feel as if they could run
into Wolverine on the street so he made
the choice to avoid including
larger-than-life villains in brightly
colored costumes like mr. sinister but
don't despair if you are a fan of the
mr. sinister character as Simon Kinberg
has now said that mr. sinister will be
introduced in a future x-men movie it
was certainly a great choice to make
Logan a very different type of movie
within the superhero genre however it
does mean we never got to see Hugh
Jackman in Wolverines classic
canary-yellow costume we did see the
suit once was only in an alternate
ending to mangal 2013 the Wolverine
movie actually before Logan was released
Hugh Jackman teased fans when he tweeted
a picture of a Wolverine action figure
in the original costume the bright
yellow costume wouldn't have fitted
neatly with the tone of the Logan movie
went for though so in the end the
closest we got was wire an easter egg at
Logan's funeral when one of the mutant
children was holding a Wolverine toy
dressed in the classic costume man Gould
has explained his decision not to
include the costume by stating that for
him Logan is the least narcissistic of
all the superheroes and that the desire
to put on a trademark outfit and prance
about doing good deeds while people
recognize and for them seemed very
unlike Wolverine in fact in the final
movie Logan himself tears into the way
events from his life were depicted in
the comics and have no time for self
promoting people in leotards as for man
Gould who believes that Wolverines
costume works best in the comics but not
so much on-screen or at least not on
Hugh Jackman in the Logan movie so how
do you feel about the deleted scenes and
characters do you think James Mangold
got it right with his final cut or is
there anything you wish he'd included
don't forget to leave a comment and
subscribe for a chance to win this
awesome Logan merchandise and if you
enjoyed this I really appreciate you
giving it a thumbs up and sharing it and
also why not check out some more videos
on my channel you might like you can tap
or click here to do just that thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
you